PROFESSOR: All right,
let's get started.
We are continuing our
theme of folding polygons
into convex polyhedra.
Let's do a quick
reminder, we're talking
about gluing up the boundary
of a polygon to itself.
And we were representing that
with gluing trees last time.
So I want to do an actual
example of a gluing tree.
So this is how you
make a cube out
of a cross, my favorite example.
And a valid gluing,
it's an Alexandroff
gluing because it
has no crossing, so
its topologically a sphere.
Everything is glued
to everything.
And it never glues more
than 360 degrees of material
to any point.
In fact, it's going to
be 270 at every point,
because that's the curvature
of every vertex of a cube.
And the gluing tree was, if we
sort of turned this inside out
and think of the polygon as
being on the outside instead
of the inside, it's really
hard to see here how to convert
that into a gluing tree,
though you can do it.
It's the way that
these arrows nest.
But it's a little easier
to think of on the sphere
or on the polyhedron, because
then turning inside out
is just upside down.
It's not a big deal.
So if we look at where
the cut are on the cube,
it looks something like this.
That should be a cross.
This is the top
of the cross, this
is the bottom of the cross.
It goes around the back side.
So then the gluing tree is
essentially this doubled.
If we walk around the
outside of the cuts,
that is the gluing tree.
So I can see, there's this
segment, then this segment,
then that segment.
Then we're back here,
then we go up one, two,
and then we turn around.
That's a leaf, and so it's
going to look like this weird h
shape.
And these are vertices.
That's right, all of
these should be vertices.
And locally you can see, ah,
this is a 90 degree angle.
This is actually the
top of the cross,
remember the polygon
is now out here.
That's going to
be the top across.
This is where it turns,
it gets a little confusing
because of the
way I've drawn it.
Here's the bottom of the cross.
Those parts are easy to see.
The rest is little awkward.
But for algorithms,
this is a great way
to think about things.
And also for proving bounds
and how many different ways
to fold, it's really useful
to think about gluing trees.
Of course, all of these
views are equivalent,
but a lot of things will
be easier to analyze here.
So, clear?
Let me first tell you what
we're going to prove today.
We're going to do combinatorial
bounds and algorithms
for all of this.
And let's see.
So I want general gluings,
general situation,
edge-to-edge gluings, and a
particular kind of polygon
called bounded sharpness.
And then I want two columns.
The first question is, how
many gluings are there?
And whenever we get a bound
on the number of gluings,
we're also going to get
an enumeration algorithm.
Remember, there are three goals.
The first goal was decision.
Is there any folding?
Second goal was enumeration,
give me all the foldings.
And third goal was
counting, I think.
How many different
solutions are there?
For [INAUDIBLE], this is mainly
about decision and enumeration.
And this number
of gluings, that's
the combinatorial problem.
So it turns out, for
everything the we'll do,
these two have the same answer.
So I'm going to put
it in one column.
But sometimes for
a decision, you
can do it a little faster
than enumerating them.
In particular, because
the number of gluings
can be exponential.
We saw last time that it
could actually be infinite.
I'm going to fix
that, don't worry.
We'll make it finite.
And then the right
bound is exponential.
There's upper and lower
bounds of two to the theta n.
And also here, bounded
sharpness is interesting
because it's polynomial.
And so this is also polynomial.
The one result here that
is not tight is this one.
It's an open question whether
for the general setup, the most
interesting scenario,
just give you a polygon,
is there any gluing?
The best algorithm we
know is exponential,
even to decide whether
there's a gluing.
So I put a star
there to say that.
It is not tight.
The open problem is, can
you do it in polynomial?
I suspect yes, but we worked on
it a long time ago and failed.
For the special case of
edge-to-edge gluings, which
is when you only glue
whole edges of the polygons
to other whole edges, there is
a n to the order one algorithm.
You can think of this as
an edge-to-edge gluing
if you imagine this
as being two edges.
If I actually draw
a vertex there,
then this is an
edge-to-edge gluing.
And then there's a polynomial
algorithm to tell you,
is there any folding?
If you want to list all
of the gluings though,
you need exponential
time because there
can be exponentially many.
But everything except
this one result
is the best you could hope for.
Bounded sharpness
is a natural sense
in which this exponential
is kind of cheating.
Let's see, let me tell you
about bounded sharpness.
I want to bound how sharp an
angle can be in a polygon.
This is a really sharp angle.
If every angle-- is that
actually the sharpness I want?
Actually, no.
Sorry, I'm getting
inside out already.
Actually, what I care
about are reflex vertices.
I don't want to have a
super big angles here.
So if every angle
is at least 360
minus some epsilon--
for a constant epsilon--
then I call my polygon
bounded sharpness.
If your polygon has
bounded sharpness,
we get a polynomial bound
on the number of gluings
and a polynomial algorithm
to list all the gluings.
This is really the sense in
which this is all practical.
Give me a polygon that's going
to have some sharpest angle,
call that the bound.
If epsilon gets really tiny, if
your reflex angles get really
close to 360, then
this bound will go up.
But as long as you're not
too extreme, you're all set.
I mean less than or
equal to, yes, thank you.
Yeah, that would
be a weird polygon
if all the angles were so big.
I think that doesn't exist.
So for example, convex polygons
always have bounded sharpness.
Epsilon is 180 in
that situation.
So, that's good.
I told you about
edge-to-edge gluings.
Just glue whole
edges to whole edges.
What I haven't really told you
is how we made this finite,
so let me go to that.
And when I say
gluings here, I really
mean a combinatorial
type of gluing,
because we had rolling belts.
So there were infinitely
many actual gluings,
but I'm going to
think of most of those
as being the same thing and
just distinguish essentially
what the gluing tree looks
like combinatorially.
So let me define that.
The first part is what I call
the abstract gluing tree.
So this is just what the
picture looks like in general.
So for example, the one
over there-- the cube--
combinatorially the
tree looks like this.
It has four leaves and a kind
of wishbone configuration.
So I'm not trying to measure
the lengths or anything, just
that's the abstract
picture, no metric.
And then the second
part is I'm going
to specify which polygon
vertices and edges are where.
And I'm going to specify that
at things called junctions.
So in particular, at
leaves I want to say,
oh this is vertex one.
At places like this, where
three edges come together,
I want to specify for each
one, oh this is vertex two,
this is edge eight, this
is vertex 10, whatever.
I'm making up these numbers.
They don't necessarily
correspond,
but they should appear in order
because this is the polygon
after all, just
warped inside out.
Also this one.
Also, I didn't really draw
this picture big enough,
but if I have two parts
of the gluing tree
where a vertex glues
against something--
it could be another vertex
or it could be an edge--
I also consider those junctions.
So junctions are going
to be all the vertices--
the only exception is when
there's an edge gluing
to an edge, I don't
consider that a junction
because there's going to
be fairly many of those.
I want there to be finite.
So everything of
degree one, everything
of degree three or
more, for degree two
there has to be at
least one vertex.
So degree not equal to 2,
or at least one vertex.
Those are junctions.
For each I'm going to
mark where they are.
That's part of my abstract
gluing tree, specifying where
the junctures are, how
they're configured.
And then for each
one, wherever there's
part of the polygon
coming together,
I specify which vertex
or edge is coming there.
Now when I specify
an edge, I don't
say what point on the edge,
because that could be infinite.
There could be a whole range
of points, there could be.
We'll worry about that later.
I just specify that
edge eight is there.
So this is what I call
combinatorial type of gluing.
And in this case, there are
only finitely many gluings,
finitely many types, but
it can be exponential.
It's still big, just
not quite as big.
So just to get
warmed up a little,
let's prove this exponential
upper bound that is only 2
to the order n.
That will in
particular convince you
that there's only
finitely many of these,
although I think that's probably
obvious that it's finite.
It's conceivable it could
be more than exponential.
This is not a particularly
exciting bound,
but we're going to use
a lot of the same ideas
in the other proofs, in
particular this one which
is more interesting.
I want to look at
leaves of my tree.
And we have to remember back
to the previous lecture, who
can be at the leaves?
Well, if could be a vertex
or it could be an edge.
When it was an edge, we
called it a fold point.
When we folded in the
middle of an edge--
so here's an edge of
the polygon and I end up
subdividing it and gluing
the edge onto itself-- right
there is 180 degrees
of curvature.
Total amount of
curvature is 720,
therefore I only
have-- I can't count,
I'm jetlagged-- four of them.
At most four fold points.
Everybody else is a vertex.
So if I have n vertices, I
have at most n plus 4 leaves.
That's already feeling good.
I pull a rabbit out
of a hat and tell you
that if I have only
n plus 4 leaves,
there are 2 to the order n
trees on that many leaves.
Actually, I should be
a little more careful.
If I can bound the number
of nodes in the tree,
then I'll get an exponential
bound on the number of trees.
And that will be part one,
the abstract gluing tree.
But right now I have a bound on
the number of leaves, not the
number of nodes.
And there's a difference
here, because if you
have a tree which has
a whole bunch of degree
2 vertices, then that would be
bad, because I only have two
leaves I have
arbitrarily many nodes.
But every time I have one
of these degree 2 nodes,
we already threw away
the degree 2 nodes that
had no vertices at them, because
there are infinitely many
of those and those don't count.
So once we throw that away,
the only degree two junctions
are the ones that have a vertex,
which is why-- these dots are
supposed to be the actual
vertices of the polygon.
So it might be an edge here,
it might be an edge there.
There's at least one
vertex at each of them.
So the total number of nodes
here is indeed order n.
I mean, it's probably actually
at most n plus 4 again.
But if we're sloppy you say,
well the number of leaves
is at most n plus 4.
The number of degree
2 nodes is at most n.
Then there could be
some degree three nodes.
It's also at most
n plus 4 in total,
or n is all I care about.
You could be more
careful and figure out
what the consonant is.
But we get from this,
this is order n nodes.
And once you have that the tree
has a linear number of nodes,
I'll tell you this is one of
the [? Kadhalan ?] problems,
that there's only 2
the order n such trees.
But that's only part one
of the combinatorial type
of the gluing.
We also have to worry about
which vertices are where.
I want to show that that
is only exponential.
So imagine at this
point you've fixed
the combinatorial
structure of the tree,
but you have no
idea what's what.
So in particular,
at these points--
and maybe also you've
defined some degree 2
junctions, which you
know are supposed
to have at least one vertex--
the first thing I want
to specify is, for each
of these little dots that
come together-- these are the
junctions-- is it a vertex,
or is it an edge?
So that's just binary
information for each one.
I'll fill it in, say
if it's a vertex,
I'll leave it open
if it's an edge.
In fact, I know that at
most one edge comes together
at any point.
Otherwise, you'd have too
much material glued there.
So maybe it looks
something like this.
It could be a fold point,
maybe another fold point.
Something like that.
So that coloring, black
and white, there's only 2
to the order and such colorings.
Call it a vertex edge
coloring, because again there's
order n dots.
Each one, there's two choices,
black or white, vertex or edge.
And now what we
really care about
is where the vertices,
because remember, this
is the polygon in order.
So if I could tell you, let's
say which vertex is vertex one?
Maybe this vertex is vertex one.
Then I know this is vertex two,
I know this is vertex three,
I know this is edge
three or whichever
edge connects V3 three and V4.
This is also edge
three, and so on.
I could just walk around
and label them in order.
All I needed to do is
know where vertex one is.
There's only n
possibilities for that.
There's n filled circles, which
are where the vertices are.
One of them is V1, so there's
only n choices for it.
You multiply all of these
things together, n times 2
to the order n, times
2 to the order n,
that result is 2 to
the some other order n.
That's total number of choices.
So that's a rough
but fine upper bound.
I'm not going to try
to tune this constant.
I guess it would
be an open problem
to get a really good
bound on the constant.
I'm not sure if even
one has been worked out,
but what I will show you is
that this is pretty much tight,
so you can't hope to do
much better than this
because there's a 2 to
the omega n lower bound
on the number of gluings.
And that is this crazy example.
I'll draw it also on the board.
It's a little tricky to draw.
It's a very spiky star,
something like that.
So I have e points, and n
spikes, n convex corners.
The convex angle,
I think, is alpha.
Let me match the notation.
Yes, convex angle is alpha.
The reflex angle here is
beta, but otherwise it's
completely symmetric.
So all the reflex
angles are beta,
all the convex angles are alpha.
I have n spikes.
I want these points--
it's hard to draw,
but I want them to be very,
very close to the center.
Take the limit.
In the limit, alpha is 0.
So alpha is going to be some
very tiny amount epsilon.
Beta.
What's the limit of beta?
180, 360?
No, it's not 360.
That's what's important.
360 times 1 minus
1 over n, yeah.
It's like 360 minus 360 over n.
Believe it or not,
this is a big number,
in that it doesn't
depend on epsilon.
So it's going to be, what,
a little bit smaller--
going to be some
minus epsilon prime.
But I really don't care
about the epsilons.
They're kind of irrelevant.
Let me just cross them out,
but they're really there.
So alpha is basically 0, beta
is a chunk less than 360.
What this means is in the limit
I can take one of these alphas
and glue it into
one of the betas,
and it will still
be less than 360.
In fact I could
glue n of the alpha.
I could glue all of these
spikes into one of these gaps.
Remember, the limiting
picture looks like this.
That's maybe more convincing.
It doesn't look that way here.
This is nothing.
Of course, I can fit arbitrarily
many of them into this gap
and it will still
sum to less than 360.
So this is kind of the key
to why this example works.
I've got tons a room for alphas
in the complement of betas.
Now, I would like to make
this not only an exponential
lower bound on the
general case, but also
on the edge-to-edge
case, because that's
a little bit stronger to say
even edge-to-edge gluings there
can be exponentially many.
To do that, I'm going to
take the midpoint of one
of the edges, call
that a vertex,
and take the perimeter antipode,
which is like here hopefully,
more or less.
So I want the left parameter
and the right perimeter
to be equal, also
call that a vertex.
And now one thing we know how
to do is perimeter halving.
Now, we were only supposed to
do perimeter halving on convex
polygons, but it turns out it
will work on this polygon too.
So I'm going to glue this
half edge to this half edge,
then I'm going to glue this
edge to this edge, then
this one to this one, and so on.
So just do that gluing.
And the only thing
to worry about
is that you glue
two betas together.
That would be more than 360.
Anything else, beta to any
number of alpha's is OK.
At this point it is really
helpful to draw a gluing tree,
so let me do that.
So gluing tree for
perimeter halving is path.
And do I give these guys
names, probably x and y?
Yeah, that's what
I would call them,
so naturally that's
what I called them.
We have x over here,
we have y over here.
And then we have the
perimeter in between.
So let's just
check what happens.
Here we get an
alpha on one side--
I'm going to say the right
side is the bottom, let's say.
I'm not going to try
to think about it.
So there's an alpha,
and that meets a beta.
And then it just
alternates from there.
There's an alpha, it meets a
beta, but on the other side.
And a beta meets
an alpha and so on.
At the end, it's probably the
reverse, like alpha, beta.
I've drawn it up
here at the very top.
The alpha's red, betas are black
so you can distinguish them.
But that's clearly an OK gluing
because it's just one alpha
gluing to one beta.
We know we can glue tons
of alphas into one beta.
That's one gluing.
The fun part is that
there are exponentially
many of these gluings which look
like this, where you take some
of the betas and turn
them into leaves,
kind of squeeze them out.
And the result is that
you get two alphas gluing
to a beta, which is fine.
The beta glues to
itself, which is fine.
I mean, it's a vertex.
It's comforting that it
has an angle almost 360.
Therefore, there's very little
curvature out at that leaf,
but we don't really
need to check that.
It is just necessary
for this to work.
Of course, beta is less
than 360 by itself.
Here's an example where I
squeezed two of the betas
right next to each
other, then three alpha's
come together and
glue to a beta.
But what's nice is we don't
have to think about the polygon.
We just think about
the gluing tree.
And we say, well if
I pull this down-- so
I end up with
that-- that's going
to be just fine as long as
I also pull one on the top.
I have to squeeze the
same number of betas
on the top and the
bottom, otherwise
these links won't match up.
As long as I do that,
I get a valid gluing.
So what I'm going to do,
I have n betas total.
So I have n over
2 betas on the top
and n over 2 betas
on the bottom.
I'm going to squeeze n over
4 on the top and n over 4
on the bottom, so half of them.
That way the lengths
will match up,
and I happen to know there's
a lot of ways to do this.
The actual number is n over
2 choose n over 4 for the top
and the same for the bottom.
So it's this
squared, and I'm just
going to tell you that
is 2 to the theta n.
Actually, I think you
can be pretty precise.
Can you?
I've forgotten.
Isn't n choose n over
2-- it's very close to 2
to the n over 2, I believe.
Is that right?
But not exactly, yeah.
All right, I'm
going to be sloppy.
It's 2 to the theta n.
You could figure out what
the constant is there.
I think I have a bound
written down, maybe.
Oh, it is the power of 2, yeah.
It is equal, I believe,
according to my notes.
So this is going
to be 2 to the n
over 4 squared, which is
2 to the n over 2 exactly.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: I only am allowed
to squeeze betas, not alphas.
But I can do whatever pattern I
want on the top and separately
any pattern I want
on the bottom.
Because what's key
is by squeezing
betas I preserve the parity,
because when I squeeze away
a beta I bring two
alphas together.
So the parity and who's matching
whom on the top and the bottom
is always the same.
And the beta on
the top will always
be matching some number
of alpha's on the bottom,
and vice versa.
So it doesn't matter what
pattern I do on the top,
or what pattern I
do on the bottom.
It just matters they
have the same length,
so I arbitrarily chose
them to both be n over 4.
Well, it wasn't
arbitrary, but I chose
it to be that
because I knew there
would be a lot of those choices.
There are more, of course.
Really I should sum this
over all choices of n over 4,
but this is good enough.
That summation would not
improve the bound by much.
So that's sort of the bad news.
These are really nasty polygons.
They have exponentially
many gluings.
For fun, we actually
did this for small n.
It's been a while.
This was some time ago
that we made all these.
I think it actually
was before 2002,
but that was when
the paper appeared.
So here is a four
star, and these
are I think all of
the possible gluings.
Maybe just some of
them, it's been awhile,
I could think about it.
Not drawn as gluing trees
here, but drawn as actual
gulings on the polygon.
Here instead of
drawing the gluings
on the outside, which
is how they happen
in the gluing three, I've
drawn them on the inside,
just because it's
easier to draw.
And then we built
them in the same way
that I built one like I showed
you last time, where we just
took a polygon, started
taping edges together,
and these are the
roughly taped versions.
And then you guess where
the crease signs are,
and then you can draw
the crease lines on here.
And two of them
are drawn sort of
worked out where exactly
the crease lines have to be,
according to getting all
the edge links to match.
And then you can
make your polygons.
That is n equals 4,
then we did n equals 8.
I guess we want n to be
even here for convenience.
And there's more, although
still not a huge number.
I think these are the top sides
and these are the bottom sides.
And you can see, in some
cases it was a little tricky
to tell where the creases
are, because they were
almost flat or possibly
actually exactly flat.
Like here they are flat.
But it's a fun exercise.
You can, whenever you
have these gluings,
reconstruct the polyhedra.
Of course now that we have
algorithms for Alexandroff's
theorem, we could try plugging
these into the programs
and they should give us exact 3D
polyhedra, from which we could
figure out where the
crease lines are.
It would be a fun, small,
mini-project, I guess,
to do that.
This is all from ages ago.
At this point I want to move
on to this result, which
is the good news.
This is sort of bad news
that there are exponentially
many different gluings.
It's not so bad in that at
least we can enumerate them
in the same amount of time.
We'll get to that later.
While we're in the
combinatorial streak,
I want to prove
that there's only
a polynomial number
of combinatorially
distinct gluings for
bounded sharpness polygons.
So of course, this
star polygon does not
have bounded sharpness.
We set beta to be very,
very close to 360.
It may be worth talking
about this a little bit,
because it wasn't exactly 360.
It was bounded away from 360 by
this value of 360 divided by n.
Now I said that
was a big number,
because it was much,
much bigger than alpha.
Bigger than n times
alpha even, because I
can make alpha very close to 0.
But it is not what we
call bounded sharpness.
Bounded sharpness was 360
minus a constant-- I really
shouldn't have called it
epsilon because it's confusing.
Let me call it gamma just
got another Greek letter.
Gamma is not arbitrarily small.
It is a constant value, whereas
over here it's not constant.
It's a constant divided
by n, that's sub-constant.
So this is not bounded
sharpness, just to check.
But if we have all the
reflex angles, at most 360
minus an actual
constant bigger than 0,
then we can get a
polynomial bound
on the number of combinatorially
distinct gluings.
So let me show that to you.
Here's the cool thing
about bounded sharpness.
How many leaves can
the gluing tree have?
Each leaf is either an edge,
like it's a fold point.
In that case, the
curvature is 180 degrees.
Or it's a vertex.
If it's a vertex, the
curvature at that point
is 360 minus the
angle at that point.
360 minus the angle,
let's call it alpha.
Now, we know that every
angle alpha is at most 360
minus gamma.
So if this is going to be
at least 360 minus gamma,
which is just gamma.
So every vertex, every
leaf of the tree,
has curvature at least gamma.
Gamma is a constant.
Total curvature is 720, exactly.
Therefore, the number
of leaves is at most 720
over gamma, which is a constant.
That's going to help.
We don't have to worry
about trees with n leaves.
We only have to
worry about trees
with 20 leaves, some
constant number of leaves.
Again, as the bound on sharpness
goes down, the number of leaves
will go up in this
inverse proportional way,
but it's a constant.
So at least for part
one, we're golden.
I mean, the number
of gluing trees,
I said over here-- where is it?
If I have n nodes
in my tree, I'll
only have 2 to
the order n trees.
So if I can reduce the
number of nodes in my tree,
I will reduce the number
of trees correspondingly.
If there's only a
constant number of nodes,
there will be a constant
number of trees.
It doesn't matter that a
constant gets exponentiated,
it'll still be constant.
So that's good news,
except we bounded again
the number of leaves,
not the number of nodes.
So we have to be a
little bit careful,
because in particular we can
have degree 2 junctions, which
are real junctions--
they might look like this
where a vertex comes to an edge.
There's got to be
about n of those,
because the vertices
have to be somewhere.
We're saying there aren't
very many at the leaves.
And therefore, at the degree
three and higher junctions,
there can't be very many.
Maybe I haven't said
this, but if you
have a tree with
L leaves, you'll
only have at most L internal
nodes, branching nodes.
But degree two nodes, there
could be arbitrarily many.
So what we come to is, if
I have L leaves in a tree,
then I'll only get 2
to the order L gluings.
This is what we need to prove.
It will tell us
that in particular,
if we have a constant
number of leaves,
as comes from the
bounded sharpens case,
I will get-- constant
number of gluings?
That's not right.
There's some polynomial
on n times 2 to the order
L. Ah, that's why.
I should look at my
notes occasionally.
The right bound to
n to the order L.
In fact, what I wrote
is an open problem.
I think maybe it's n to the
order 1 times 2 to the order L.
This is what you'd call a fixed
parameter tractable bound,
but no such upper
bound is known.
That might be fun to work
on in the problem session.
It might not be difficult,
just at the time
I didn't know those
bounds were important.
So we still have
to prove this, n
to the order L. This is the
part where my notes are wrong.
Here's the idea, we have
a small number of leaves,
we're worried about
these degree 2 junctions.
But I claim, actually
there isn't a lot going on.
Because one of the
great things we can do,
over here we said for
every dot, was it a vertex
or was it an edge?
We can't afford that anymore,
because there's n dots still.
We can't afford
2 to the order n.
Where we can afford it is at
the leaves, because there's only
L of those, and at
the branching nodes.
So everything except
these degree 2 problems
we could specify.
And really we could
specify anything we want.
So yeah, we could specify, is
it a vertex or is it an edge?
But we could make
life even easier-- hm,
I have an idea for
solving this open problem.
Do I want to solve it right now?
Yeah, let's do it.
Let me think for a second.
I think that's going to work.
OK, cool, cool.
I needed to rewrite
these notes anyway,
so I might as well
prove a stronger result.
All right, so let
me draw a picture.
There's branching nodes, and I
surely draw one of these longer
so I can say, oh there's some
degree two junctions here.
Those are annoying,
ignore those.
For everything else-- the
leaves and the branching
nodes-- I'm going to specify
the same binary thing.
Is it a vertex,
or is it an edge?
But now there's only
order L of them.
There's L leaves, so there's at
most L minus 1 internal nodes.
Each of them has some
degree, but the total number
of these dots will be order
L if I ignore the degree 2.
So that's 2 to the order
L vertex edge colorings,
just like before
except now with L,
of leaves and branching nodes.
Oh, I see the problem.
Darn it.
What I'd like to do is mimic
the same proof and say, well
choose where V1 is and then
just label them around.
There's a problem
with that, though.
Say V1 is here.
Where's V2?
Well, maybe this is an
edge, maybe this is an edge.
This, I have no idea.
Is it an edge?
Is it a vertex?
I can't tell.
At degree 2 junctions,
I have a problem.
That's kind of annoying.
To fix that-- and so this is
still going to be open, alas.
To fix that I need to-- I
really want to know which dot
is which vertex for
reasons to be determined.
But in particular, that
is part of number two.
So I'm just going to give
up and say, well there's
2n different things that they
could be, n vertices and edges.
Do I want to do it that way?
Maybe n choose order L. I'm
just going to write down
wherever I have a filled dot--
I guess this one is not filled.
Maybe this one's filled, filled.
I just going to write down,
what is the vertex number there?
This is maybe V3, V5,
V20, V21, whatever,
for each of the filled
dots among the vertices
that I can see, ignoring again
the degree two junctions.
There's order L of them.
I just going to for each one
pick out one of the labels.
Again, the order is
determined, so this
is the right number of them.
And this is n to
the order L at most.
So this is where I'm
being a bit wasteful.
It would be interesting
to try to get around that.
This was actual
vertex labelings.
So now, among the
vertices I can see--
the degree three
junctions, and the leaves,
and higher degree
junctions-- I know
which vertices are glued there.
I can also figure out
which edges are glued there
by similar labeling, although
I don't think I actually care.
No, I probably care, because
it's part of number 2.
So I do have to also label
the open circles which
edge is there.
But a similar bound holds.
What's left?
What's left are the
degree 2 vertices.
I don't know
anything about them.
This is particularly tricky
when I have some edge here.
But let's first
think about the case
where I have a
vertex, add a leaf,
and I have these
degree two junctions.
And I don't know which edge
is here, which vertex is here.
In this case, because
everything's small,
I might be able to figure out.
But here, where's the
V3 to V4 transition?
Could be here, or
it could be here.
It could be here.
I can't afford to figure it out.
Fortunately, I don't
have to figure it out.
It's not so obvious.
From this picture you
can't see what's going on,
but this came from a polygon.
This is an actual vertex,
this is an actual vertex.
So this edge length is the
total perimeter from V3 to V5
along the polygon.
I know how long that is.
So also if that was
going clockwise from V3
around the polygon--
actually, that's
probably counter-clockwise
in the polygon
because everything's inside out.
If I go the other way--
let's be relative-- from V3,
I can measure out
the same length.
So in fact, I have
some polygon-- maybe
it looks like this, whatever.
I go from V3 to V5, and I
measure out that length.
And I go the other
way from V3, and I
know this is getting
glued to that.
So I know where the vertices
are from the lengths.
I can figure out exactly
what this picture must
be when I have-- in
this case, I happen
to maybe get a vertex
going to another vertex.
In general, probably get some
vertex gluing to some edge,
and maybe vice versa.
But if I can figure out
exactly what that pattern is,
I can figure out the
label of these guys,
because I know exactly
what's happening there.
So that's good.
If it's a vertex to vertex edge
in the gluing tree like this,
I can figure out everything
between that pair.
Is that enough?
Almost.
So if I have a leaf where
this is a vertex, which
I was usually denoting
by a filled circle,
I have various
degree 2 junctions
which I ignore until I get
to a degree three or higher
junction.
Now at this place,
even just looking
at this dot and this dot,
I know at least one of them
must be a vertex.
Because I can't glue two edges
together plus other stuff.
I can glue at most one edge.
So maybe this one's an
edge, like in the picture
that we did before.
But one of them
has to be a vertex.
And then I can figure out
exactly what's happening there,
because I have this
vertex to vertex thing.
And I know the labels.
I know this is V5 and
this is V13, whatever.
I know exactly what's
happening on the right side, I
measure backwards, I
know exactly what's
happening on the left side
and who's going to what.
So that determines everything.
The problem is when
I have an edge here,
because then I don't know
where it is along the edge.
I can't measure lengths
anymore, somewhere
in the middle of the edge.
And indeed, if I have
something like this,
where all of these angles--
I mean this for example
is in a convex polygon, this
could be a perimeter halving--
and it's not determined
what's happening here
because this is a rolling belt.
I'll show you how
undetermined it is.
Suppose you have a bunch
of vertices like this,
and then some
vertices like this.
Depending on where I
bend around for E5,
these guys could be here.
They could be here,
or here, or here.
They could be in the
middle straddling this.
In fact, there are about
n squared different places
where these guys could be,
relative to these guys.
Because there's going to be n
transitions from-- if this is n
and this is n-- n transitions
from this versus that guy,
then n transitions from
these versus that guy,
n transitions versus that
guy, total of about n squared.
Actually if this is n and this
is n, it's exactly n squared.
So we're not quite
done, but I claim
that there's really only
order n squared left.
It's always from
the rolling belts.
We know from last time there's
at most three rolling belts,
so at most quadratic per belt.
So total outcome is
polynomial for what's
left, what we haven't specified,
for how the degree 2 vertices
behave.
These are all
degree 2 junctions.
It's here, or they're
here, we don't know.
So if you want to get the full
specification of what's where,
you do all this work.
And then for the
degree two junctions,
you have to deal with
the rolling belts.
The way to prove
this is say, well,
if I have a leaf that's a
vertex, I can get rid of it
and induct.
In the end, I'll have
at most four leaves
because there's at
most four fold points.
So I have a constant
number of leaves.
You look at each
belt, each of them
is quadratic and polynomial.
If you work out the
bounds here-- we've
tried to be a little
more precise--
you could prove an overall
bound of n to the 2L minus 2
for L leaves.
And we have slightly better
bounds for L equals 4
and L equals 3, but
that's pretty good.
But the proof I gave is
at least n to the order L.
We could n to the order L
count different things here,
and then some N to the
constant at the end.
This ends the
combinatorial part.
Now we're going to
get to algorithms.
So we've proved all
of these things.
Exponential upper
and lower bounds
for the general case
and edge-to-edge case,
and polynomial for
bounded sharpness,
or when you have a reasonable
number of leaves in your tree.
I'm going to start with this
edge-to-edge gluing algorithm.
This is going to use a technique
called dynamic programming,
which some of you have seen
before, some of you haven't.
It's a very simple idea.
You take your
problem that you want
to solve-- which is
I have a polygon--
and you split it up
into sub-problems.
You solve each of
the sub-problems,
and one of the sub-problems
is actually the whole problem,
and then you're done.
In our case, a
sub-problem is going
to be some sub-chain
from one vertex
to another vertex
of the polygon.
So I have some
polygon, and I just
look at some interval of
the boundary from VI to VJ.
And the idea is, well suppose
that VI is glued to VJ.
How many different
ways, or how should I
glue the part in between?
How should I glue
this into itself?
Because there's no
crossings, there's
going to be no gluings
from inside to outside.
So that's the sub-problem.
And of course if I say from
the interval from V1 to V1,
that is the entire problem.
Of course V1 is glued to V1.
So in particular, the
V1 to V1 sub-problem
is what we want to solve.
So this is our goal.
So I'm going to tell
you how to solve
all of these sub-problems,
and therefore
how to solve what we
actually want to solve.
That's dynamic programming.
So let's try to solve one of
these sub-problems, VI to VJ.
How are we going to solve it?
So I'm going to draw a picture.
It looks like this.
This is now thinking
about the gluing tree,
so the polygon's on
the outside here.
That's one of the main reasons
gluing trees were developed,
just to describe this algorithm.
This algorthim's
actually quite old,
1996 by [INAUDIBLE]
and [INAUDIBLE].
The edge-to-edge case was
before I joined this group.
And then later together
we did the general case,
unbounded sharpness, which
is what we'll do next.
So this is at the
heart of everything.
So we have VO to
VJ glued together.
We want to know how to
glue together the rest.
Well, maybe some vertices
get glued in here in addition
to VI and VJ, maybe not.
Let's think about what
gets glued to this edge.
There's the edge
from VI to VI plus 1.
And this is an edge-to-edge
gluing, so what
gets glued there
is an actual edge.
What edge could it be?
Some edge over here, I
don't know which one.
The power of the
dynamic programming
is you don't need to know.
It's some edge, VK, VK
plus 1 gets glued there.
There's only one of them,
it's out there somewhere.
It has to have
matching edge length,
but there could be many
choices, all of which
have matching edge length.
Maybe all the edge
lengths are the same,
but there's at most n
choices for that edge.
It's actually at most J
minus I choices plus 1.
But there's at most
n edges in here,
so there's at most n
different possibilities.
Just try them all.
Think about all of them.
I haven't said here whether
I'm doing-- or I have?
I guess I've been pointing here.
I really want to do both of
these algorithms at once,
but I'll start with this
one, which is just find
all the gluings in
exponential time, which
is optimal in the worst
case because there
can be exponentially
many outputs.
So try all n choices
for VK VK plus 1.
What happens when
I do one of them?
I might choose one of them.
Well, the new picture will
be-- so the topological picture
is I still have VI glued to VJ.
Then I also have here VK and
VI plus 1 glued together.
And I have VI also
glued to VK plus 1.
Now it's possible
actually VK plus 1 and VJ
are the same thing, in which
case there's no loop here.
And that's the case
when no extra vertex
got glued in there.
But this is the
generic situation.
If this is link 0, then
these guys are the same.
So really what I have now are
two different sub-problems.
There's this thing, which
is VI plus 1, dot, dot, VK.
And there's this one which
is VK plus 1 dot, dot, VJ.
The idea with the
sub-problems is
to solve the
sub-problems in order
by increasing chain length.
So start with very short ones.
And I saw longer and longer
ones using the previous results.
If I've already
computed the answers
to VK plus 1 to VJ
because that is smaller
than the original--
look, there's
two edges fewer at least.
This thing is at least 2
smaller than the original chain
because here's two edges.
So I wanted to solve VI to VJ.
I guessed what VK
to VK plus 1 was,
meaning I tried all the
possibilities for each one.
I say, well what are all
the possibilities for this?
What are all the
possibilities for this?
Take the cross-product.
Just multiply those
sets together.
Those are all the
possible gluings.
And then I sum that.
I take all the options for
all the different values of K.
And that's it.
That output is all
the possible gluings.
So this should actually
give another way
to prove that the number
of different gluings
is only exponential, but this is
just for the edge-to-edge case.
Maybe I should write that down.
So we have for each
choice of K output--
let's say, and for each
solution to the smaller
sub-problem VK plus 1 to VJ.
And then for each solution
to VK plus 1 to VK output.
This is very simple.
This is just a product
over various things.
There's only order
n choices here.
This thing, it depends
how many solutions there
are to those sub-problems, but
it's the product of the two.
And then that's
the total output.
Believe me, this runs
in exponential time.
That's not very hard to prove.
What's interesting
is we can make
the same algorithm with
a little bit of tweaking
get a polynomial time
decision algorithm.
That's cool.
How do we make it a
polynomial decision algorithm?
I can't afford to store every
solution for every sub-problem
because there can be
exponentially many.
So I only get to store one
solution for every sub-problem.
So this is the great idea.
Let's say for each sub-problem,
let's say VI to VK only store
the solution that
minimizes the amount
of stuff glued into VI VJ.
So the sum of the
angles glued at VI,
which is the same thing as
VJ because they are already
glued together.
That's what we were told.
So I had many choices here.
I had all the choices for
K. I had all the choices
for up here.
I had all the
choices for up here.
Well actually now I'm just going
to think about one choice up
here, which is what
is the choice that
minimizes the angle glued here?
And what is the
choice over here that
minimizes the angle glued there?
Why the minimum?
Because some of these are wrong.
I should actually say
output if it's Alexandroff.
We only want to output
Alexandroff gluings.
We only want to
output gluings where
the total sum of the angles
is less than or equal to 360.
I need to check
that for every one.
If I want to have the most
chance of it being Alexandroff,
if I got the least possible
angle glued here and glued
here, that's my best
hope of it working.
Now I still have flexibility,
which is I get to choose k.
There's still n choices
for k, but everything else
is determined at that point.
Once I fix K I see, well
does this work, yes or no?
If it works, that
gives me one candidate
for how much material
gets glued here.
It could be a lot,
could be a little.
I try for all K, I
take the smallest one.
So it's the same loop, except
there's no four loops here.
It's just for every
choice of K, I
look at the solution to VK plus
1 to VJ, the solution for VI
plus 1 to VK.
If it's Alexandroff,
I don't output it.
But I check, is it the best
solution so far in terms
of the total angle
glued of VI and VJ.
I keep looping until I
find the very best one,
and I output that one.
That would be the
solution that I store.
The result is, the running
time is actually polynomial,
because the number of
sub-problems-- a sub-problem
is determined by two vertices.
There's only n of
these, n of these.
So the number of
sub-problems is n squared.
For each sub-problem I need to
look at order n choices for K.
And so the total
running time is n
squared times n,
which is n cubed.
And that will tell
you if there's
any hope of anything
working, if there's
any gluing this will find
one, because it's always
trying to minimize the angles
that get glued together
That's is edge-to-edge.
Now we can generalize.
It's a little bit
messy, but we can
generalize to arbitrary gluings.
Let me sketch a little
bit how that goes.
So we've seen now this result
for algorithms and this result
for algorithms.
And now I'm going to tell
you about this result.
I wish there was a result
here to tell you about,
but there isn't.
So this last part that I did
where the decision algorithm is
very efficient, we don't
know how to generalize that
to the general case,
arbitrary gluings.
This only works
for edge-to-edge.
We assumed a whole
edge, VK VK plus 1
was glued to VI VI plus 1.
But the enumeration
part where we said,
oh just give me
all the solutions,
that we can get to work.
It's just slightly
more complicated.
Let me tell you how it
gets more complicated.
So one difference is that there
are more kinds of sub-problems,
this is the heart
of the problem.
We have the VI to VJ sub-problem
just like before, that's easy.
And then we have the
VI to EJ sub-problem.
So this one was VI was glued to
VJ, very clear what that means.
Here we have VI is
glued to an edge EJ.
The trouble with that is we
don't know where on the edge
it's glued.
It's somewhere on the edge.
This is where
things get trickier.
And there's also
the symmetric case,
of course, where it's EI to VJ.
But we don't really
need to worry about
that, it's symmetric.
So what does a
solution look like?
So before, a solution
was an entire gluing.
Now, because the
gluings can be infinite.
There can be infinitely
many different gluings.
I can't actually list
every one explicitly.
I've actually got to
explain ranges of gluings
if I have any hope of
capturing all of them.
So what a solution
is going to look like
is the combinatorial type of the
gluing, which was this stuff.
You have an abstract
gluing tree,
you get which vertices
glue to what edges.
So you have pretty
much the whole picture,
just not exactly where each
vertex is glued to which edge.
Then I also will tell
you a total angle
of material glued at VI so far.
In both these cases,
I want to know
how much stuff in
my gluing at VI
so I can tell whether
it's Alexandroff.
And then in the case where I
glue a vertex to an edge, what
I'm going to do is
give you an interval.
The Interval's always
going to be starting at 0,
and going to some
value x. x is less than
or equal to the length
of the edge, VJ.
And this is the interval along
the edge where VI can glue.
So I'm going to tell
you an actual interval
here from the edge EJ.
As long as you glue VI
to somewhere between
there and there,
this stuff works.
Whatever I specified
works over there.
You can't go beyond some point.
That will turn out to be enough.
So while there's the VI to VJ
case, it's less interesting.
Let's think about now if
I want to actually solve
the VI to EJ case.
What could happen?
Before there was
only one-- we looked
at what glues VI to VI
plus 1 and it was one edge.
It was a little
easier to think about.
Let's not think
about the whole edge,
but let's think about locally
what happens just after VI.
Something gets glued there.
Now it could be EJ
actually gets glued there.
It could be we continue gluing.
That's kind of like
zipping, although not
exactly what we were
calling zipping before.
Here I call it
zipping, good choice.
So one option is that you
zip for a little while.
Now, how long would you zip?
A couple options.
You zip until you
hit a vertex, you
can't stop in the
middle of two edges.
So maybe you hit a
vertex here first,
maybe you hit a
and the next vertex
here is farther away.
So there's two pictures.
Let me draw the two pictures.
It could be hit you
hit VI plus 1 first.
So here's EJ.
It could be you hit
the vertex of EJ first.
In this case, you
get a sub-problem
which is VI plus 1 to EJ.
These are glued to each other.
In this case, you get
this vertex, which I think
is VJ gets glued to the
edge EI, which is just
the symmetric case I
was talking about here.
Edge EI is glued to Vertex VJ.
So those are smaller
sub-problems.
You solve those, and
then from that you
will see whether this
actually gives you
a solution to the
original sub-problem
you wanted to solve.
That's the zip case.
There's another case
which we call tug.
In the tug case-- so
that was supposing,
we'll maybe nothing
else gets glued in here.
But maybe another vertex gets
glued in there, that's the tug.
To pick a vertex, I pull it in.
So in that case we get
a picture like this.
So here's EJ, here's
VI, and now there's
some other vertex VK
that gets glued in there.
Which vertex?
I don't know, try them all.
Just like before,
before we were choosing
an edge that gets glued in.
Now it's not necessarily
a whole edge,
but if there's any
vertex that glues in,
pick who's the next one.
And now I get a sub-problem
here which is VI to VK.
I get a sub-problem
here which is VK to EJ.
I solve each of those, I
take the cross-product,
I do that for all values
of K just like I did here,
except the labels have
changed a little bit,
and I find all the outputs.
And again, you can show that
it's exponential time at most.
So that's an algorithm.
Now, it's exponential time,
but really it's not so bad
because it's at most
cubic like we had before.
But we're doing
extra work, which
is something like the
number of gluings dealt
with at each stage
per sub-problem.
Now, it's not just the
number of actual solutions,
because we generate
all possible solutions
and then check whether
they're Alexandroff.
So if you have some example that
happens to be unique in the way
that it glues up, this bound
will not actually be very good.
It's still going to
consider lots of options.
But in the case of
bounded sharpness,
where the number of gluings
is only polynomial--
and it's polynomial
for a strong reason
that the trees can't
get very complicated--
then we can actually turn this
into a polynomial algorithm.
This will be n cubed
times that bound.
As long as your polygon
is bounded sharpness,
you can show that at every stage
of course the number of gluings
will also be polynomial.
And so then even the
number of gluings
you have to consider and
check will be polynomial.
So the whole thing will
be polynomial time,
that is this result
and this result.
So if your polygon is
vaguely reasonable,
this is actually a
really good algorithm.
This algorithm has
been implemented
by two groups, one
[INAUDIBLE] in mathematica
and another [INAUDIBLE],
which sadly is not--
his implementation
used to be on the web,
I can't find it anymore.
But you get either
implementation,
plug-in your
polygon, and it just
lists all the possible gluings.
So that's all the
theory for today.
Now I want to show you a whole
bunch of gluings for fun.
Once you have all the stuff,
we have these programs,
you get to play.
So our first play is not that.
That was the last play.
First thing, we saw this before.
I'll just remind you
what it looks like
and tell you a little bit
about what's going on here.
So this was the cube.
And then it's eventually
going to fold into a cross.
The real study here is
for the Latin Cross--
which is the picture
I keep drawing
at the beginning of lecture and
which will now be unfolded--
what other convex polyhedra
can you glue that polygon into?
So it's like you're not
told what the creases are.
You just want to look at
gluings, the resulting creases.
This is one convex
polyhedron you can make.
This is something that can
come from Alexandroff's theorem
that you actually get a flat,
doubly-covered convex polygon.
It's technically a polyhedron,
according to Alexandroff.
These are all edge-to-edge
gluings if the length two edges
are actually subdivided
into two length one edges.
And this video only enumerates
the edge-to-edge gluings,
because at this point we only
had the edge-to-edge algorithm.
I forget, this video
is '98, I think.
This algorithm was in '96, so
they had just implemented that.
And then that's when I joined.
I was just starting out as
a grad student and said,
OK let's make a video.
That would be cool.
So I think there's one more.
And this is the only
one where we actually
have the animations.
This octahedron, this
was tricky to find,
beceause at this
point there were
no algorithms for
Alexandroff's theorem.
So we found it by taking
a piece of cardboard,
gluing it up,
getting a protractor,
and measuring all
the dihedral angles,
and then typing them in.
And Lo and behold,
in that animation
they don't perfectly close
up, but it's very close,
up to the measurement
error of the protractor.
So for edge-to-edge
gluings, there
are exactly five
convex polyhedra
you can make from that cross.
But if you allow
non-edge-to-edge gluings--
and so some years later when
we came up with that algorithm
and implemented it, we
discovered there are 85 gluings
of the cross.
This is only six of them.
We're going to do it
starting with the cube,
and then we're going to go
in increasing order of faces.
So there's two flat,
doubly-covered quadrilaterals.
They're different.
Then there is a bunch of
tetrahedra that you can make.
None of them are regular.
One of them was edge-to-edge,
I think it might be this one.
I think there's some more
tetrahedra at the top there.
The blue labels here
say what they are.
For each one of
these we taped up
the-- we knew what
the gluing was.
We taped it up, and
then we played with it
until we figured out,
this must be the creases.
Then we actually drew
in that create pattern,
folded it up, and verified
that is the right answer.
Because again, at this
point no algorithm
for Alexandroff's theorem.
More tetrahedra.
Here we get to the
five-sided polyhedra.
I think this one is edge-to-edge
and is in the video.
It's a little hard to
tell from the-- actually,
you can tell from the pictures.
Here there's two sevens.
That means seven glued to seven.
That means this is a
fold point, this edge
is glued to that edge.
Over here, every edge
has only one label,
where again this is
considered two edges.
So this was the
edge-to-edge gluing.
I think a couple more slides.
We get another
pentahedron and then
starting to get hexahedra other
than the cube, lots of them.
Then we start getting octahedra.
The last one in the
video was octahedron.
It's not this one, this
one has some fold points.
It must be-- these
are all octahedra,
so it's one of these.
This guy.
Of course, it's hard to
tell from a static image,
but yeah, obviously that was
the octahedron from the video.
And that is all.
So actually, there's only
23 distinct polyhedra
you can make, but you can
make them out of 85 gluings.
So 85 gluings.
If one of them is symmetric,
the cube is symmetric.
So that's one.
And then the other
84, there's everything
and its reflectional
inverse, because this polygon
is symmetric.
So it's 84 divided by 2,
which is 42, a good number.
42 actual honest
gluings plus the cube.
But those 42 gluings,
a lot of them
generate the same
polyhedron, because there's
only 23 distinct
polyhedra in the end.
I don't have it here,
it's on my web page.
You could look up
all 85, and it says
which ones are the
same as which ones.
And it was a real surprise
when we were building them.
It was like, wait
this looks identical
to this other
polyhedron, and it's
glued in a very different way.
Sort of an extrasymmetry
of that polyhedron,
as opposed to the cross itself.
It was pretty cool.
An interesting
thing to note here
is that we only bisect
the edges, right?
There's a lot of
edge-to-edge stuff,
and then some of the
edges get cut in half.
And in this case actually, they
look mostly like fold points,
but that's not always the case.
It turns out, if you have a
polygon were all the edge links
are the same like this and
you look at non-edge-to-edge
gluings, and there
are no rolling belts--
because if there's
rolling belts,
it's infinite because you're
not going to have anything like
this.
Then it suffices to
subdivide every edge in half.
And then every non-edge-to-edge
gluing will become
an edge-to-edge gluing.
This is called the [INAUDIBLE]
half-length theorem
in our book.
It was proved by
this guy [INAUDIBLE],
who was one of the
implementers of the algorithms
for enumerating
all these gluings.
And he proved it afterward.
The code doesn't actually
exploit that fact,
but it's kind of neat.
All you have to worry
about are half edges
in this case where all the
edge links are the same.
All right, that's a cross.
And it's kind of
maybe even surprising
that there's only finitely
many different gluings,
but there's no way to
get a rolling belt here.
Let's look at-- oh, here
are all the polyhedra
in a pretty 3D form.
Here is a polygon
which is convex.
It is the equilateral triangle.
And so, no surprise, there
a rolling belts here.
But here's the picture of
how all the rolling belts fit
together.
In principle, you can
extract this picture
from this algorithm.
Although combined with an
algorithm for Alexandroff's
theorem, that's the tricky part.
So you have some
very simple gluings,
like could could fold
the triangle in half,
get this doubly-covered
triangle,
you can make a
regular tetrahedron,
or you can fold the triangle
into a flat doubly-covered
rectangle like at the top.
And then there are
rolling belts in between.
So this is one
rolling belt, this
is another possible
rolling belt,
another possible rolling
belt each with a gluing tree.
They're not all drawn here.
And this is sort of
the topology of all
of the possible gluings you
could make, which is nice.
So a triangle is
relatively simple.
The square is a little messier.
There's again a bunch of
particularly nice gluings
like the [INAUDIBLE], the
folding in half one way,
folding in half the other
way, making a letter,
and some tetrahedra that
are just drawn here.
They're in the middle.
And then there's these
crazy rolling belts
for how they fit together.
So this is in unit square
all the different gluings.
And one of the fun things,
some of them are octahedra,
I have a list here.
But I don't know actually
which one of these belts
has the octahedra.
It might be a couple of them.
And it turns out, for octahedra
they actually figured out
an algorithm just for octahedra
to solve Alexandroff's theorem.
This is again before
Alexandroff theorem algorithms.
And they wanted to compute, well
if I take all these polyhdra,
which one has the
maximum volume?
So if I take a
square paper, what's
the maximum volume
shape you can make?
And there it is.
It's kind of fun.
One of those octahedra.
And this is a prettier picture
of-- so here they actually
computed all the polyhedra.
Obviously not all
infinitely many of them,
but various snapshots
along each rolling belt.
And each of these
rolling belts corresponds
to one of the circles over here.
And that's it.
Any questions?
So that's the end
of fun with gluings.
We'll look at other kinds of
gluing problems next class.